the rise in terrorism following the Iraq
war has mainly been plastered in the
Arab world that the countries
surrounding Iraq you've seen a five
times increase in vail jihadist attacks
in the Arab world and that's countries
like Saudi Arabia that's countries like
Egypt Morocco Algeria you've seen a new
wave of terrorism there after the Iraq
war you had very little terrorism in
those countries in 2001 and 2002 but
after March 2003 you really do see a new
wave of attacks in those countries now
that's partly to haddis groups in those
countries taking inspiration from what
was going on in Iraq and that's also
people starting to come out of Iraq who
have been trained in Iraq veterans of
that conflict who were spreading their
savoir-faire how to make bombs how to
make an improvised explosive devices
persuading jihadist groups in these
countries that suicide bombings is
attacked it which will work and so we've
seen a rise in suicide bombing attacks
in countries all around the Arab region
Saudi officials are now very very
concerned that there's going to be
blowback coming from Iraq that Saudi
fighters and almost half of all foreign
fighters going to rock a Saudi are
coming back to Saudi Arabia their
veterans their radicalized they're angry
and there's real fair that they're going
to go after the Saudi royal family and
the institutions have stayed in that
country we've seen a number of plots in
Saudi Arabia in 2007 we've seen hundreds
of arrests there we've seen plots in
Algeria very late on in 2007 there was
an attack by the group called al-qaeda
in the Islamic Maghreb on the United
Nations in Algiers and many people died
in that operation we've seen the tax in
Morocco Tunisia elsewhere in Egypt
following Iraq the Terrorism rates went
up so the Iraq war was a shot in the arm
for al-qaeda but that of course is not
the end of the story because the Iraq
war has also exposed one of Al Qaeda's
Achilles heels which there is a tendency
of the organization to indulge in
barbaric acts of violence to act as an
oppressor towards the local pop
nation in 2006 al-qaeda launched a spate
of attacks on sheer targets within Iraq
it's now turned its sights on Sony's the
Sunni areas of Iraq it's trying to put
its will into place by violence
essentially bullying the local
population and there's been a really big
backlash in Iraq against the
organization we've seen the emergence of
what you call awakening councils in the
country which are Sunni groups some
former insurgents former allies of
al-qaeda now turning against al-qaeda
they've been effective in reducing our
cardiss presence in Anbar and elsewhere
in Iraq and you've started to see al
Qaeda weakened significantly in Iraq in
the last month even though it's still a
in the country to be sure but this this
behavior in Iraq from al Qaeda has also
been very very important in persuading
Muslims around the world some of whom
had some sympathy for some of what was
up what al-qaeda was doing and of course
this is a small minority in Tony against
Al Qaeda because they've seen what
happens if you'd let al Qaeda around the
leash and they don't like it they don't
like the scenes of bloodshed the
headings of torture of chaos that
they're seeing in Iraq they don't want
that to be the future of their country
and so bin Laden is less popular than he
was a few years ago because of events in
Iraq because of events elsewhere where
Al Qaeda has gone off to Muslims in
Saudi Arabia went after the royal family
that many Muslims have died and attacks
more Muslims have died and attacks
launched by Al Qaeda many more than them
Westerners around the world al Qaeda
operations in London and Madrid in the
West have also turned off the Muslim
community there in those countries there
was some sympathy for what al Qaeda was
doing around the time of 911 that is
really kind of all gone now there's been
a real reaction within the Muslim
community the emerging criticism of al
Qaeda has come not just from mainstream
Islam not just from the Muslim
establishment and countries like Saudi
Arabia not just from organizations such
as the Muslim Brotherhood but
also come now from former associates of
bin Laden from Mujahideen who fought in
Afghanistan in the 1980s from scholars
who bin Laden admired there's been a
real emerging criticism coming from all
sorts of parts and constituencies of the
Rama community around the world and this
is going to in the years to come be a
real problem for al Qaeda because al
Qaeda are killing Muslims they're
launching attacks on innocent civilians
they're torturing victims to death
Muslims don't like this sort of behavior
from whatever constituency they come
from and because with you know
fundamentally Islam as a religion of
peace and so this has been very very
counterproductive to al-qaeda and when
you have key scholars when you have
people with the credibility of those who
fall in Afghanistan now turning against
bin Laden that is important because
youngsters really respect these sorts of
figures they date they've been following
and for years and when the scholars that
they follow are now telling them if you
become a suicide bomber you're going to
go to hell that's certainly being
listened to and causing a lot of doubts
and I think in the years to come is
probably going to turn off the tap of
recruits to al-qaeda so we might be at
the peak of the problem right now